hi friends welcome back to the uh Linux
networking commands my friends in the
previous session we have discussed 10 uh
Linux networking command and in today's
session also I'm going to discuss
another 10 Linux networking command my
friend so let's start with command
number 11 my friend but if you are new
to this Channel please don't forget to
like share and subscribe the channel and
press the Bell icon for the latest
notification my friend please do
subscribe to this channel more and more
so we can grow this channel together my
friends so friends let's start with
command number 11 and in this command I
am going to change the default gateway
of my rhl 9 of my Linux operating system
so uh the command which we are going to
use over here is root add default
gateway 192
16872 do1 my friend and this command is
we can use it for manipulating the
routing tables my friend okay so let me
show you so here you can see if you run
the command you already know know we
have run in the previous session so what
is the current uh uh Gateway over here
is this one so this one I'm going to
change with which command root and then
add
default that is Gateway and then
192.168 do
72.1 my friend enter so now you run the
same command and check you can see the
default gateway I have added this one
correct so let's move on to the next
command my friend so the next command is
IP tabl henl okay this IP table hyphen L
is Administration tool for ipv4 packet
filtering and
net so if you run IP tables hyphen l so
it's going to see so over here there is
no as of now I have set any policy or
chain over here so this this is
absolutely a flushed IP table so if you
set here any policy or anything so you
can restrict the traffic my friend okay
so let's move on to the next command my
friend that is TCP dump hyon
i0 means why we use this command to dump
the traffic on a network okay if you can
run the command called
TCP Dum hyph I and then just give the
interface name what is your interface
name so for that we need to run the
command before this one if have config
so all the commands are Interlink with
each other this is why I'm showing all
these commands to you my friend okay so
you can see the interface is not e zero
over here okay so the interface over
here is this one right so I am going to
run the command my friend that is TCP
let me clear this one first okay
TCP dump I and then I need to give my
interface name over here right enter so
you can see I am getting all the output
over here Dro previous to TCP dump okay
so you are getting all the outputs here
my friend my host name is not set so I'm
getting all the outputs over here so
it's going to take time to give the
complete output so what I'm going to do
over here is I'm going to do a control C
so you can try in your system what final
output is coming here my friend so
friends as you can see that I did
control C because it's going to take
time so the video will be very lengthy
so you can try it from your end uh right
so you can check the complete output and
this is how this command Works my friend
TCP Dum I and you need to give the
interace interface uh name my friend so
friends uh let's move on to the next
command the next command is your SS HD
service normally you know SSH we use it
that is secure shell to connect uh to
any machine virtual machine okay so if
it it is mainly for open SSH demon that
is
sshd d stands for demon over here so if
you have to restart your sshd service so
why we do this command my friend why we
run this command let me show you first
of all so this is my virtual console so
you will not get access to this one
directly and this is the mobile EXT or
we I we can call this one as your
normally SSH or you can say like puty
same it's a uh remote login client SSH
client also we can call it as a okay so
if you see here if I run this command
system okay sys system CTL okay
status
sshd do service my friend okay so you
can see this particular service is
running so as soon as I stop this
service this SSH connection will be lost
and you are going to get the error like
network connection error something like
that okay so if I'll do a system CTL
stop okay so I'm going to lost my
connection it's asking me by password
because this requires a super user
permission my friend okay so it's failed
it's access denied let me try once
again with the command sud sudo see this
time it works my friend okay so as soon
as this one so I lost my connection now
after this one after that you are going
to lost the SSH connection so you will
not be able to connect through puty okay
and you'll be not able to connect
through any secure shell my friend that
is SSH client and here also if you run
this command that is system
CTL
okay and
Status
sshd do service okay so you can see
currently the service is in inactive
okay and if you have to start this
service
okay just do a start over here okay so
you can see see now if you run the same
command now the it's in active phase my
friend so this is how we troubles sshd
do service means open SSH issues my
friend okay so friends let's move on to
the next command that is tet command and
uh as I told you compared to SSH tet is
not secure my friend SSH is secure
command normally if you use this command
explicitly you need to install this
command in your Linux operating system
my friend so here uh tet command we use
it for user interface to the Tet
protocol so let me show you how we can
use tet command my friend
okay uh uh let's first see whether tet
command let's first see whether tet
command is installed or not so just run
command called
tnet and just give
ww. google.com my friend so you can see
clearly uh it's telling that uh there is
no tet installed so for that what you
need to do is you just do a run run this
command so run this command my friend uh
you can run this one
dnf
install tnet okay
Enter so it's going to check some okay
so it's asking me that whether you want
to install or not so I'm going with
install so you need to install this one
explicitly but remember as I told you
tet is not secure command Okay in org
level also you need to get permission
because tnet command uh if you use tet
command so chances that when you're
trying to connect to a server in between
packet loss will happen and Intruder can
hack your machine also this is why we
use SSS that is secure shell it using a
tunneling and it's using a encryption
also my friend when you are connecting
to a mode server okay by using any
client SSH client okay so yeah let's
come to the
point see now it's telling that it's
trying to connect my friend okay if I
can see uh if it will not trying to
connect so you can try to see uh with
some other server also this is how it's
going to give output I'm going to give
my own server
Earth original.com
okay so it's telling trying to connect
my friend okay so if both are internally
connected if you have to check some port
is open or not so and the IP also you
can check the connectivity from this
server because I have both the server
DNS is different okay both are in
different network so obviously it's not
going to give me any output you can see
it's it's connection refused okay so if
both will be in the same network okay uh
all the network connection are well
placed then you are going to get a
proper output for this one otherwise
it's going to tell you network is
unreachable like that okay so this is
how we can use tet command my friend and
you can try this one also okay let me
show you tet and then 192 do 168
72112 okay just see this is the next
server here also you can see this is the
server my friend so if I do if config
for the other server this is the IP okay
the same IP I have tried to put over
here so here also it's not coming
connecting there is a reason behind that
one you need to do a DNS setup okay so
both the server both the server name
server should be uh we need to put DNS
name server should be same then only
this tet is going to work out my friend
okay so friends let's move on to the
next command that is WG command and get
command is used for non- interactive
Network downloader if suppose you want
to download any package from your
internet you can use WG command my
friend so here I'm going to download a
vsftpd package so let me show you how we
can download by using wget command my
friend so this is the package uh I'm
going to copy this one okay and let's go
here just run this WG okay and just
paste over here and enter so you can see
the package is downloaded and even if
you do a ll over here you'll come to
know it's downloaded in/ T directory my
friend okay so let's move on to the next
command my friend that is C command and
C command is used to command line tool
for transferring data with the URL so
I'm going to show this one with my own
uh website so you will come to know how
exactly a curl command is working my
friend okay so just clear this one and
run this command called curl and you can
give
https colum
sl/
Earth original.com okay so you can see I
am getting a complete HTML off so it
means the data transferring is happening
and my website is absolutely fine and
it's up and running my friend okay I'm
getting all the HTML Pages my friend and
all the links and URL and
everything so friends let's move on to
the next command and that is nmap
command it is very important so normally
nmap command will be not installed to
your system so what I would say that
please use nmap command and you can
install same way like I have installed
the Tet so it is mainly used for Network
exploration tool and security scanner
okay so you can use this command uh nmap
hyphen small S and P okay so let's see
how it's working over here and there is
also one more thing friend uh for this
you need to register your rhl machine
rl9 to Red Hat Network and for that what
you need to do is C friend so this is
the command you need to use uh I'll put
this one in the description okay so and
you need to give your uh rhl means the
website the portal okay username and
password and you'll be able to register
with RL Network my friend okay so I have
already done this one so this is why my
Y is up to date okay so friends just run
the command called n map hyphen small S
capital P 192 do 168 do
1.0/4 so it's going to scan your
complete Network range my friend
here it's going to take time to give you
the output but you need to wait for some
time so friends you can clearly see uh
we are getting the output with the nmap
command so let's move on to the next
command my friend uh that is if stat
command and this command we use it for
Handy utility to read network interface
statistic my friend so let me show you
how we can use this command so if you
run this command if
if stat enter so you are going to get
the output like this my friend and if
you want to know more about if stat
command okay so if stat command just do
it like this here you can see it's
neatly print out the network interface
statistic the utility keeps record of
previous data displayed in the history
files and default only shows difference
between the last and the current call my
friend okay so this is all about if stat
command my friend so friends I'm ending
up the session here only thank you for
watching this video for more videos like
this just stay tuned to my channel and
don't forget to like share and subscribe
the channel my friend till then just do
take care of your loved ones Jin and
bye-bye my friend